a lifetime friend has three common
traits and they're very rare So if you
find someone like this they are a gift
in your life the first is is this person
someone that when I have bad news I can
call them will They Mourn with me rather
than being secretly happy that I failed
second is when I have good news can I
call this person and they will genuinely
be happy for me and celebrate with me
the third and the least likely to find
is someone who can do both of the first
two and do so without immediately trying
to relate your story and your
circumstance to themselves if you can
find someone who can do all three you
found a rare gift